Let's quickly pick up on our caller from the
7 0 8, because 7 0 8 has been just holding
on for so long.
7.
Oh, wait.
What's your name and where you calling from?
Hey, David, I'm John from Chicago.
Hey, John, what's up?
Not too much, John, by the way.
Yes, John.
I must I misspoke.
And I did hear you.
You know, so probably it's probably The New
Yorker.
And they even though I'm in Chicago, I have
a question about the Europeans on the response
that people have been given relative to everything
lately in America.
Now.
I know there have been good stories and it
seems that there have been people that have
been almost, you know.
Taking care of their fellow man and brother
and sister excuse me.
But at the same point in time, it seems like
there are a lot of people that.
Have been vitriolic and very dark, and I was
wondering if you think this is more or less
a morality or an education thing or possibly
both, because I've been a fan of yours for
a while and I highly respect your intellectual
take on certain sociological things.
You know, I wish I had a strong answer for
you.
Here's here's the thing.
I have thought for a long time and I think
it's probably a naive thought that if there
is really a global calamity or a global an
incident of global importance, I sometimes
will say, imagine if we found intelligent
alien life that this would so quickly make
all of our day to day conflicts obviously
irrelevant and not worth fighting over.
And we would unite against or with or whatever.
Like, you know, we would realize we're not
alone in the universe.
This is a major step forward for mankind.
We would fix or instantly resolve a lot of
the minor conflicts or we've got a global
pandemic.
This risks killing millions and millions of
people if we don't actually deal with it.
Everybody's coming together and you've got,
you know, people with ridiculous signs wearing
no masks.
All of us together and all these different
states, people calling for the firing of Dr.
Anthony Fouche.
Like it would almost be insane if aliens did
show up.
And we sat them down and we said, listen,
we've got this global pandemic.
We've got no real treatment.
The vaccines a year off.
And here is what these protesters are doing.
And here's what people are demanding about
Dr. Foushee.
The aliens would say, what the hell is wrong
with homosapiens?
They would get back on that spaceship and
fly away.
Right, because it's insane behavior.
So I don't know if it's political polarization
that's causing this.
I don't know if it's ignorance that's causing
this.
I don't know if it's bad people or a combination
of all of it.
But it's if we can't come together around
this.
I don't know that we can ever really come
together as a as a as a human race.
Yeah.
I would totally agree.
And I'm happy to hear you bring that analogy
about the aliens.
And I know you have other callers, but I just
as a teacher, because I'm in private music
teacher and because of the obvious virus,
my life has changed quite a bit relative to
doing everything remotely.
And teaching guitar, bass and violin remotely
is kind of annoying.
But the thing that I've noticed the most is
that some of the students that I have around
here that I could still kind of safely go
to their house and teach them because I'm
obviously find myself.
There is always this philosophical argument
that tends to be posed to me because I think
people don't realize that.
A lot of people are affected.
Like I just lost my uncle last week ago in
New York to the virus and stuff like that,
and I mentioned it to one of my students parents
and they were basically going off on how it's
not just Trump's fault and stuff like that,
in which I could arguably do the mental gymnastics,
honestly, to see that argument.
But there's also a point in time where I'm
like, shouldn't you just kind of.
Did a little bit more compassionate relative
to wanting to be right.
Like I think Stephen Fry said this in a in
a in a lecture that he did, but he's like
the biggest problem with humanity right now
is not the point of being like our biggest
problem is that we want to be right and not
be effective.
Yes.
Towards everyone.
I don't disagree with that.
And it is true that this is not just Trump's
fault.
Every country is dealing with it.
And the idea that we would have had no deaths
is a silly idea.
Trump's response has been a failure, but it
is bigger than Trump.
That doesn't excuse Donald Trump's behavior.
John, I really appreciate it.
I've got to run to a commercial break, but
it's been so great hearing from you.
I'm sorry, I was not able to get some more
calls today, but we will take calls again.
And I appreciate everybody who did call it
The David Pakman Show David Pakman Dadgum.